so in my restart of making more content
I'm actually doing a gmail interview
right now gchat so while Laura is typing
I'm going to make a quick piece of
content one thing I've been really
fascinated about as we all talk about or
at least I do about storytelling how
storytelling is really how you do
business and how you put out content on
Facebook Twitter Tumblr Pinterest
Instagram Google+ all these platforms
and I think about this quite a bit I
think that too many people are looking
at social media is one thing while not
respecting how different the community
even know if you're the same business or
same person on tumblr and on Facebook
how different they are even though if
it's the same person so I've been
thinking a lot about storytelling and
the nuances and Manor thinks about is
how do we properly story tell in these
platforms respecting the native tongue
of these platforms because they're quite
different but something that we come
more and more fascinated by lately as
mobile how mobile is the place where we
consume so much and the dirty secret
that nobody's really talking about is
even though on desktop Facebook and
Pinterest and Tumblr look very different
when it comes to here when you open
these things up on your apps they kind
of look the same big core piece of
content community actions I think that's
one of the big things that we all need
to start figuring out is how are we
going to story tell on the platform
that's delivered on this while
respecting the nuances of the platform
and neeps looking at me right now yen a
I'm doing both Nate I'm multitasking
that's how you make [ __ ] happen
storytelling platform and what it's
delivered on start paying attention
because 2013 is going to depend on it